it's cake week here at the show
i know it's 20 20. we have to have cake
week and our next guest makes some of
the most
iconic and incredible and instagramable
creations her cakes have exploded
on social media including her popular
rainbow explosion cake
i am such a huge fan of hers
and i actually am lucky enough to know
her a little bit
please welcome the founder of flower
shop
amira kasem
hi drew i'm so excited i'm so excited
first of all congratulations i hear coco
is about
four months old now oh my god yes
she is my little unicorn that i get to
play with
every day it's so so so exciting thank
you
well i have to say you're such a
colorful beautiful
whimsical person i can only imagine what
getting to grow up in your house will be
like for her
well i hope it's rainbows and unicorns
and sprinkles and sunshine because
that's exactly how i decorated her
nursery with
our pottery barn kids collection so she
literally has
sprinkle wallpaper in the hopes that by
the time it's her first birthday she
will just want to
dive into one of these cakes and just
smash eat it on the whole thing
we're gonna get to make your famous
unicorn rainbow cake
and i can't wait to do this with you
should we start decorating absolutely
so i have here my famous frosting it is
cream cheese frosting because i just
love you know the richness and the tart
sort of cuts the sweetness a little bit
and so what i do is we're going to start
piping
almost as a triangle just so we have a
base of
so i start with the center i'm going to
make a little flowers
and that's sort of our front that we're
going to start with and then you can
just grab
literally any color okay i'm trying to
copy you and i'm just
botching it oh don't copy me the the
whole thing with cake making and
decorating
is how much fun you get to have and make
it your own and make it unique
you know i know that about what was it
eight years ago
that you sort of took a big risk and
quit your job in fashion to pursue this
dream i mean holy cow did it pay off you
have collabs with
you know every big brand out there but
was that just such a scary risk and how
did you have the courage
to do it oh my gosh totally leaving your
job
and not knowing where your next paycheck
is coming from
is pretty much scary to anyone but i
figured
if i believed in myself enough and i
worked super hard that i could one day
have
a bakery and let alone an entire brand
like you said i have a collection with
vans and just so many different crazy
things
by the way i have the vans i forgot to
wear them today oh i'm so mad they're in
my closet they're my new favorite shoes
thank you for sending them to me
they are fun
i'm gonna put the ears in i'll show you
they're little chocolate ears that i
made for us
and then these little horns i actually
make out of cutting
uh um oh my god i can't think of it oh
an ice cream cone
ice cream is my favorite thing we have
it in the la store i don't know why i
couldn't think of ice cream
but they're mini ice cream cones because
you had a baby four months ago
and the brain takes a while to normalize
there's a reason they call it baby brain
baby brain is in full gear right now and
did i tell you i had coco
literally the day we were opening the
store in la i was in the hospital
giving birth at the same time oh my god
i think that's how they define true
multitasking
um yes oh also so you now have
this new book out the magical land of
birthdays
the mystery of the birthday basher and
this is your second book in the magical
land of birthdays
and i have to tell you that my two
daughters their favorite book to be read
to to go to sleep
is your first cookbook the power of
sprinkles i love that
okay we're gonna cut are we ready try
and go all the way to the center of the
cake
yes okay here we go thank you i'm like
this must be done right okay
there we go no do you know what it is
you're opening it towards the camera
which is
not the natural way do not be hard on
yourself i'm trying to feature it
you ready yeah see now watch how it's
done two
wait a minute
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh how did you come up with this
idea what was the aha pinatas
i grew up in mexico pinatas were the
biggest
part of any birthday right so i just
always looked forward to that moment
where you get to smash something and all
the candy falls out
and when i moved to the u.s
i saw less and less of it and as an
adult you sort of
celebrate your birthday by going to a
restaurant getting a dessert with a
candle on it and i'm just kind of like
when you're young you're like when i
grew up i'm gonna do whatever i want and
play with bubbles and eat sprinkles for
breakfast and as you grow up you tend to
shy away from that so i wanted to create
something that brought back
all the childhood memories for me that
everyone could celebrate
anywhere you know at home or anywhere
and still get sort of that big surprise
reveal moment
amira i'm gonna take that with me
throughout the rest of 2020 and deep
into 2021
we are adults let's not lose sight of
all the things we promised we would do
when we were kids thank you so much for
bringing
no thank you drew the most famous of the
cakes to cake week and be sure to visit
flower shop
and pick up a copy of her book the
mystery of the birthday basher
or the power of sprinkles her cake
cookbook which lives
on my bedside table
you